okay let me see something slightly wrong
with my setup here
um how old
okay
um
well hello everybody uh
we are talking about molecular computing
um
and
uh let's see did somebody send me an
agenda here it's in dropbox
so
general box
okay okay okay
is it under molecular computation
correct so general box research no no
you don't need to tell me the whole part
i asked you is it under molecular
computation the answer is yes where is
meetings and then live streams okay all
right fine thanks
it's the one such thing that's there yes
okay fine
um
you know in general they're just
meetings the fact that they're live
streamed is purely coincidental
um okay
so some of you who were not here earlier
um
we were discussing in a different
meeting
um
uh
something which is just so bizarrely
convergent evolution it's
kind of funny
um this is pattern matching
for molecules
and this this is uh
basically graph rewriting and for
example this is a quintessential
multi-way system wherever we had it down
here where this is
i don't even know what this is this is a
reaction apply
of
to something or other i i guess that all
means do it in all possible
uh match it in all possible ways is that
cut right that's right
okay so this is like it's just a
freaking multi-way system here it is
these are
so
actually i'm a little bit confused here
why the left-hand sides flip around is
that just purely friend
oh that's weird okay so these are
different i mean you have different
reactants uh with different uh
substructures in them that are matched
uh that can match either
right so so you so yeah basically what
you're saying is and this is where we're
not doing sub chemistry we're doing
chemistry role and sub chemistry what
you're saying is you've got a
you know you've got a
liquid or something which has a bunch of
this guy and a bunch of the sky in it
yep and then what you're saying is those
can be matched you can pick those out
any way you want
yes these are all the tuples and and
both molecules can play both roles in
the reaction
you're matching stoichiometric
concentrations of these no no no no no
i mean you're just like rewriting some
molecules
i mean so stoichiometric coefficients
right so so the pattern or the uh um
like the template for the reaction has
like a list of substructures that are on
the left and
substructures that are on the right and
they get transformed into them
and so you search for
the first substructure inside the first
molecule you give it you search for the
second substructure and the second one
you could give the molecules to the
function in reverse order and you would
get a different reaction okay so i think
that's a little different than
okay so
in our world
this would be like a token event graph
and these are the tokens
and the tokens can be picked up
let's see the
tokens
in the other notebook stephen the first
section has this exact system in it okay
fine
the deals older one
okay here we go
okay uh somebody had already done this
and published
their multi-way graph of it yeah
this is good
yeah
well it's not convergent but um it can
go on forever and ever
i've redone it using our tools um
and here is just the first step
of the same two molecules there at the
top uh and and the way they can do it
this is the result of doing it uh
okay for
four iterations
what happens if you deduplicate here
with with molecule like some what it
is so these are isomorphic molecules
these molecules are not isomorphic
everyone is different
everyone is different
okay
so
and but if we made equivalence classes
of these molecules is there a natural
equivalence class to make for these
molecules
because what would i mean by equivalence
class okay so what i mean is in this
picture here well maybe these people
just didn't go as far as we've been able
to go
perhaps they didn't
my question would be this
okay we can imagine if you're doing
graph rewriting that every
distinct twisting and turning of a graph
would be distinct okay
but
we
make an equivalence class of isomorphic
graphs
by saying those twistings and turnings
are not significant all that matters is
is the graph
isomorphic yes okay
okay so in this case
let's pick out a couple of these guys
let's see if i can
oh why can't i edit this why can't i get
into that well whatever
let's pick out i don't know these two
here
which clearly are different i can see
they're different
yep
but for example if i wanted to get a
zoomed out view
of this
what is the way of sort of chemical
summarization so for example one very
straightforward thing i can do is just
stoichiometry of some kind
or just
what what is the term when you that
isn't it isn't stoichiometry i just want
to do like like um mass spectrometry so
to speak i just say how many how many
atoms are there in this thing
both of those would have the same number
of atoms but in in the mass spec
experiment you would get slightly
different spectra because the bonding is
different and they would fragment
differently
but that's probably too much detail well
no no actually let me understand that
okay the physics moment okay about mass
spectrometry
um
so
i mean
in the original story you can tell
isotopes apart and you can just you're
just fragmenting the thing and you're
just saying you're just putting the
thing in a magnetic field and you're
saying you know how do they how do the
different atoms
you know
right at the atom level
at the atom level the different isotopes
uh will hit the detector at different
times because of their different masses
in the chemical sense um it's the same
thing the the fragments hit the detector
at different times because their masses
are different
the two molecules when they are ionized
in the experiment
uh will fragment
differently based on the bond energies
and and things like that right so the
molecular mass of this of these two
molecules will be slightly different
because
the total mass will be the same with the
what's called the the parent ion
would be the same
but the
masses of the fragments
are are very likely different because
the composition of the fragments are
different okay different numbers of
atoms physics moment again okay take
this thing and put it in a mass
spectrometer okay let's actually let's
be a little bit concrete because i now
now that i'm learning how to do i'm
trying to learn how to do this okay so
let me just um
ah let's see
let's go
and we need to learn and we need uh
emerald friends to be um i'm gonna look
up their mass spectrometer so that we
can actually see what we would actually
type in
to get um
let me just see
ah
um
[Music]
let's go here
okay where do i go here
liquid transfers property measurement
the spectroscopy near the
near the green bar
what about mass spectrum
oh they say mass spectrometry there we
go
okay
okay an esi qtof mass spectrometer okay
so let's see where is the documentation
for that
here we go
okay
all
right so prepare sample okay we got a
little pipette there
okay now what does this do
so they're two different these two
different so we ionize the thing
i don't quite understand all of this but
this is how i thought this worked yeah
you you're just right
it passes through this time flight okay
so this one is pure time of flight right
and that one is given a charge on the
ion there is a certain voltage so you
put a certain energy into the into the
thing and depending on the you know that
defines the kinetic energy but then the
velocity is determined by the mass is
that correct
uh yeah the magnetic field uh determines
uh how quickly they get accelerated as
well
in that small i guess that's the
acceleration chamber there
and the smaller thing and then
they hit the detector at the other end
right and so here we see the mass to
charge ratio so this is like right
yep yep
okay
all right and and each of those lines is
a peak and it represents a a collection
of atoms the mass of a collection of
atoms okay but so when this is done to
it what you're saying is it breaks into
a um
uh
it the the molecule breaks up in some
way
yes
and it breaks into fragments of some
kind
right
i am
great and one of the things to do is try
to take the masses that you observe
and figure out what the composition of
atoms are they can give you that mass
and then sort of do the reverse
do a jigsaw puzzle and try to reassemble
what the whole structure is from the
you know what you can learn about the
fragments
but so unlike for example dna where when
it's broken into
uh you know for shotgun sequence and
it's broken up it's going to break
randomly at different places presumably
when it's ionized like this it does not
break randomly is that true
uh no there are some
well-known rules about how they break
based on the relative strengths of bonds
and structures and things like that with
the case of proteins and dna because
you're dealing with so many
repeating units like that they actually
use the exact mass of the fragments and
then they can tell exactly how many
nitrogens oxygens carbons and hydrogens
are present and then which residues they
represent is it an alanine is it a
proline is it a guanine or a cytosine
and the combinations of those so that
spectroscopy is a little bit different
than organic uh mass spectroscopy
okay here another one in my just uh you
know
uh
these modern you know length thousand
reads that you can get
in one of these you know nanopory things
how does that work you're like pulling
the molecule through something and
you're watching some something as the
molecule goes through some membrane is
that correct
i'm not sure what you're referring to
here yeah
the technology that the the the post the
the you know the newest technology this
nanopore technology for doing
sequencing
not the traditional one
not the sort of
gilbert whatever it is thing yeah i'm
not familiar with it
um
the usual way is digesting the the
protein and
one residue at a time and i know yeah
right i know
this is i think this is something where
you're pulling it through some membrane
and the reason i'm bringing that up is
in our efforts to study our observer
theory
and um you know chemical observers and
things that might be highly relevant and
we should look it up i'll look at the
nanopore sequencing case for observer
theory yeah okay
um
okay so just just as a sense here i just
want to understand what we're actually
you know down at the i mean this is this
is really cool and we really have to
actually use this doesn't look like cool
is there click the copy for this i saw
that there was for when's it
so we have to do is assemble our
notebook and we too can do i i just um i
know that they have all kinds of checks
so that you can't blow up the equipment
and things
um because i'd worry about that in my
case
um
uh
all right oh my gosh
um
forgive me are they actually doing the
experiment or is this all um
computational no that's it's real all
right okay and they've got the
instruments and and you design your
experiments computationally
and it's an automated lab as i
understand it too yes yes i was just
going to ask if it was
yeah nmr's been doing this sort of thing
for a while
right so they've done about they have
like 200 experiments that they've done
this for
ah that's bad they shouldn't go back to
there we should we should ah the good
old days
what a picture of that lab
human beings
yeah but they don't have safety glasses
on either yeah they're probably
pipetting from their mouths too but
was that a thing
oh my gosh yeah
you mean you suck the pipette with your
with it rather than having a little bulb
at the top or something oh yes
if you were comfortable smoking while
you had volatile organic solvents around
pipetting was the least of your concern
interesting but they were all done
unfortunately
okay
uh okay so let's take a look back at
this okay so what you're saying what i'm
trying to understand is
in a sense this is defining
a you know
we might call it a metachemical space
this thing you know in other words where
is
where are these molecules relative to
each other this is defining that by
their ancestry in this picture
that is
um okay but there's also
a
you know
what is it a cusa kind of space or
something where you just say like if i
for example were to draw this out
according to the boiling points of these
materials
then i would get some completely
different embedding and i would say
which things are close to which other
things but i'm trying to understand
if if you would isn't there don't we
have a bunch of these molecular
fingerprint
um
quantities that we can compute for these
molecules we
definitely could yes
okay so in other words what's happening
here
this is telling us based on this so
these events
are what let me understand what this
event is
so this event is the combination
each event
yep the the leftmost the leftmost event
takes two of the six-membered ring
molecule
i understand which is a different thing
from your intramolecular interaction
yes this is the intermolecular
interaction between identical molecules
yes
okay
and just just so i know i mean again
you guys have to humor the fact that i
know no elementary chemistry
what what's an example of like a really
common
you know you just take
copies of the same molecule like you
heat them up and then something
different happens when they interact
is that a really common example of that
um
i mean normally when you have a molecule
of a particular thing
it'll just sit there in a little test
tube or something right
and because it is an equilibrium
i know it's because it's stable it just
sits there yeah
right but i mean the things are
interacting well okay so the point is
that they may be colliding with each
other but those collisions do not lead
to reactions right to any rearrangement
like this one does right right but if
you heat them up uh then they have
enough energy that when they do collide
that bonds get
reformed okay so what's an example of
that
um
bob would that be just and the simplest
case would be just some small molecule
um
yeah is something okay a drug that would
fall apart if it gets too warm in your
your uh
cupboard in the in the that's one thing
i'm trying to think of a simple one
something that would have for example a
a carboxylic acid group on it
and you heat it up and you end up losing
co2
just just the height just the body
needed the from the voice bonds are
totally different afterwards
yeah but that's a single molecule i mean
what we're seeing here you know you know
what we need we need to we need to see
if tayo would actually maybe if if
it's kind of random to ask him right now
but but if if um if corey is here maybe
you could reach out to teo and just ask
him if he feels like joining us
we'll probably have something that
explodes
um
can somebody do that please i'll do that
sure
um
uh right but okay but so we don't know a
great example of that but this
will this reaction actually happen in
real life yes
yes
okay so this what is this molecule here
it's called uh
yeah you put me on the spot and i'm
drawing a blank um
can i pick that molecule up here and
just type it in
what is that thing that that's is that
the equals what which part of this is
that molecule
uh that's everything that's that right
right there so let me just understand
i'm again i'm trying to understand our
system and so on okay so if i take that
smart string
okay
and i type it in as a molecule
and it's not
well i guess so but it's not what you
think it is it's so that's a smart
string which means you would give it to
a molecule pattern i know but i'm
complaining
right this should work
why does it not because well i mean that
one works sure but it doesn't give you
it doesn't mean the same thing that it
meant in a molecule pattern there are
plenty of smart structures that would
not work and shouldn't work well okay
hold on hold on a second a smart
structure contains named atoms suitable
for transformations correct no no that's
that's separate right so but the smart
structure can contain something like
n or c or s or
or nitrogen with three hydrogens on it
or something like that
so there should be a function do we have
a function
like our isomers function that will just
resolve
a smart string into all its possible
actual concrete molecules
no
i mean uh
right i agree
okay
all right but then then this would work
then we would resolve that
and um
does does molecule when you feed it
something
does it it it should recognize that this
is actually a smart string and turn this
into a molecule pattern do you agree or
is that wrong
there's a um i would have to give that
some thought like so normally the idea
is that it either i think
i think that's wrong okay like integer
of string one also doesn't make the
integer one
fine okay but then or it's going to give
an error message then if i feed
molecules something that's obviously not
a smile string it's it should complain
oh yes
so in this case that is both valid
smiles and a valid smarts but in the
smiles case it means
specifically those carbons have no
hydrogens they have they have okay so
how do i find an electron molecule can i
ask what do we call it
of molecules right this is cyclohexene
benzotrine trine
triene
it's because there's no hydrogens on it
so it it's it has three triple bonds in
it
instead of three double bonds so if i
say here i'm just trying to learn how to
do this if i say here include hydrogen's
arrow true
it still wouldn't because the string
specifically says uh they're not there
yeah yeah so
how does it say that
because of the square brackets
i see
it it says take what's on the inside
literally
okay and is that what it oh i see
because it's the pattern that doesn't
have the hydrogens on it
yeah
right arguably there should be a way to
transform between these things
yeah we just haven't built it yet
right i mean so we have been looking
into a
general converter from a uh
um
from a smart string to the wolfram
language representation but it's uh and
it would cover most cases
okay all right fine we're not there yet
all right okay all right so so getting
back to your original question that that
cyclic molecule that was reacting is
cyclohexadiene
and you could probably just type in
molecule open bracket quote
cyclohexadiene
which i can't spell so you can well i'll
spell it for you
you can get the cyclohexa part
hexa
d-i-e-n-e there you go
that's not the world's most wonderful
message if i might say so
that is that is almost illiterate
where is that it's not so illiterate to
those of us that took organic chemistry
one and two no i know but it's ambiguous
due to the following that's the part
that it's due
so that i mean that's too much of the
raw message that we're getting back and
it could be uh cleaned up that's great
all right okay my minor point
okay unsaturation of bonds of hex
what does that mean
try one comma two cyclohexadiene
maybe uh oh one three
one comma three dash
the issue is where to put those double
bonds
multiple places for it so it's one to
one could have been one two one three or
one four in the middle
magnificent okay so there's our molecule
lovely
okay so what we're seeing here
is this critter is rearranging itself
well it's joining to another copy of it
yeah i understand
so can we actually see that happen let
me let me just save this somewhere
um
okay
can i do the reaction here
uh let's see
if you go to the top of the notebook and
evaluate the code section first you'll
have all the pieces
okay and then uh evaluate the line that
says deals alter equals that defines the
reaction template
okay and then you should be able to
evaluate
those
i forgot to paste in those molecules my
bad
okay
can you can you send me those molecules
yeah
um
okay so let's take a look at what you're
doing here
this is pretty cool actually
[Music]
so this here
this is a token event graph
where you're taking
at every step
the two elements that are used in this
the two elements here that are used in
this
uh
in this reaction
i can't believe we've never done this
thing of highlighting pattern variables
in the language and we have to go all
the way to chemistry to realize that's a
good idea
anyway
um
okay so here
i don't quite understand why there's
this delete duplicate products
thing
and i'm suspicious that that isn't going
to give the right answer
no it does i just uh in the chat i sent
you the uh the two molecules
okay
zoom chat yeah yeah okay
okay two molecules great
okay so now
this is what we're doing here
i wonder if it's going to be i wonder
how much harder it's going to be to
specify for emerald to actually do this
reaction this would be a good exercise
i mean we could take these these
things right i believe that they when
you do it with emerald they have a
certain store they have a cache of
chemicals and otherwise you order it
from
sigma aldrich or something yes yeah yep
yep and these are
real you know dime a dozen
okay
so then what we would do to do this
reaction is
we would
order this stuff and then we say put a
certain amount of each of these in a
test tube
and then what how would
either heat them or irradiate them with
ultraviolet light and the reaction
starts happening
and you let it go so long and then you
take the
mixture and run it through an hplc and
separate out all the stuff
but it won't stop after just one
round it'll just keep create they'll
just keep reacting and you'll end up
getting you know a great big mess
right you'll end up getting this pattern
this picture here you'd get a lot of
that yes some of these probably won't be
made because of uh
3d geometry reasons
where some things might not be able to
get close enough together to react
okay but but so normally i mean is this
essentially like a polymerization
reaction
this is sort of
sort of
it doesn't move quite as aggressively as
a polymerization right
bob
yeah usually in in polymerizations you
it's again with double bonds but they're
forming long chains and here we're not
forming uh the chains
well they seem to be getting pretty
chainy here well they are yes the rings
are are the beads on the chain uh which
is a little bit different than something
like pine uh
polyvinyl chloride polymerization
which has what in there and it's using
it's a c double bond c with a chlorine
on it
okay and those double bonds uh
the double bond
you you activate it and the double bond
becomes a single bond and that pair of
electrons from the double bond
uh
it
attaches to another uh vinyl chloride
molecule forming a single bond between
them
and then that that molecule's double
bond then goes and forms another one to
the next monomer that it bumps into and
it just keeps going and you end up
forming a long chain of single bonded
carbons with chlorine so now if we were
to i mean again
ultimately there are a bunch of odes
in the normal formulation of chemistry
that would tell us the concentrations of
these molecules is that a true statement
i mean
a rate constant
each each one of these
um events
has a certain rate constant association
yep
that's true
and in general so if we knew all those
rate constants we could predict the
concentration of every molecule here in
our if we knew those rate constants for
the given
um
uh
you know for the given temperature
pressure and so on we could predict
uh given that when we do path counting
here that will give us the
stoichiometric
you know amounts of each of these things
and then we should be able to predict
how much of each thing we would get am i
right
pretty much yeah yeah okay
so so from this
uh but but computing those rate
constants is really hard is that a true
statement
i think so yes i don't know if we've got
the
ability to do that i thought predicting
rate constants in general was really
hard
yeah you have to do methods of initial
rates or other you know multiple like
you would have to run this experiment at
multiple times at different
concentrations so that you could have
um
enough experiments to line up with all
the variables in those odes right so i
understand so that's a reverse
engineering approach where you're trying
to deduce from this thing you're trying
to experimentally measure the rate
constants but i'm asking right from
first principles
yeah from first principles you'd have to
do some kind of uh
electronic structure calculation and
calculate the energy of the ground
it's a it's not just an electronic
structure calculation it's a dynamic
calculation
right and i thought there's these r
matrices or whatever they are which are
the chemists version of s matrices and i
thought that those were pretty out of
reach or am i wrong
i'm not familiar with them i don't know
i mean like
like normally when you collide two
molecules you try and work out what's
going to happen
that's
that's in the super difficult to do
category i think
yes
okay that that would be
okay fine but then but then here
up to stereo issues
of things you know of some of these
molecules here might in fact you know
fold back on themselves if you drew them
in 3d
um in a first approximation this is
what's you know this this is a
representation of what's going to happen
in this set of chemical reactions
yeah
and um
all right so i would love to see an even
more minimal case of this but i think i
understand roughly what's going on here
and um
let me try to understand what would you
so
then there's chemical theorem proving
right so can we yet do that
will our existing theorem prove it do it
no no no uh i've thought about that and
uh
i think part of it's a representation
thing
um the theorem proving thing takes
uh variables as it were and
we would be trying to
uh
do something like uh trying to prove
that five plus two equals seven okay
where five is a molecule and two is a
molecule
but nick you have
meth i mean like if i picked out this
random molecule here i could absolutely
do find shorter
final place path right yeah yes yeah
nick would this work with find replace
path
wait from the replace path takes
the list of qualities you have to form
with like the same way as final
occasional proof does it
i see but these are
these are
token event
type structures
so do you have a a theorem proving
technology that would go i mean so what
what would the theorem want to be the
theorem would be extracting it
extracting the proof from this graph
that's correct i want to know
these are the two chemicals that i order
from sigma aldrich and send to emerald
right and i'm trying to produce that
molecule there
can you find a pathway to it with a
known
well i want to find a sub graph
yeah what i'll basically be finding is a
sub graph that ends in that molecule
well that's doable i i have that in the
survey process example in the notebook
okay yeah that okay that's just graph
theory that's that's easy yeah i know
it's graph theory right but but it's
graph theory up until this thing becomes
giant and has 10 to the 10 nodes
right in other words the question is are
there techniques for finding that path
in a sort of logic programming type way
um
that for
for this reaction yes because the pieces
we're dealing with the same pieces just
be a matter of finding the right
combination
of the six-membered ring pieces and the
five carbon pieces
um
that would fit together appropriately to
give you that structure
and so so you but you're giving me a
chemistry answer and i mean what we need
is a more general graph theoretical
answer or something
you'd be looking for a graph partition
okay but but essentially you're giving
me a theorem proving strategy that would
work for
okay so that's a very interesting idea
that basically you know normally we have
a sort of algebra inspired
what this is is graph related relations
so to speak and i don't think we've
thought about that yet unless nick
perhaps has of of essentially theorem
improving so this is actually i think
jonathan had a version of this of of
theorem proving for wolf models which
must be the same type of thing right
where you're theorem proving
where you're trying to find paths
in
um
uh
what am i trying to say you're trying to
find paths between graphs so to speak in
the space of graphs
okay through through a set of rewrite
rules that's correct yeah and that then
the question is what are the efficient
ways to do that
and i i'm now recalling that jonathan
has done some work on that
yeah that would that would probably be
just what's needed here
right so that so that's kind of what we
have to track down we can ask jonathan
about it nick do you know anything about
that
well basically what journal engineer is
encoding
the graphic writing as an algebraic
rewriting
so he had like multiple operators for
different artists of hyperedges for
example
something like that
as soon as you encode your replacement
writing as just a replacement on this
hyper algebraic hyperages you can just
set up
like an input for find equation i see
so could we do that do you think
for these for these molecules do you
think that would work
it would be
a little bit messy because if we do it
algebraically it will break
so maybe that's not the right technique
yeah the other difficulty is annotations
on the graph
right
by the way there's a chemistry question
from simon here could the rate constants
be calculated from the sum of bond
strengths
well so i mean that speaks to the
thermodynamics of it like right what the
heat is
but the rate of reaction has to do with
the the difference between the ground
state and the transition state yeah
right
but the bond strengths will will tell
you whether the reaction can happen or
not because if the thing is
if the is that not correct i mean in
other words if you've at a certain
temperature
you
i mean you
if if the final state
is of
higher energy than the initial state
the reaction isn't going to happen
unless you put heat in is that correct
yep
right but then there may be transition
states that you have to get to but you
can think of it if you want to think
about in terms of states there is a
transition state you have to reach
before you get to the final product from
the reaction but in reality
there you know the concept of a
transition you see
okay i can translate this into particle
physics those are called resonance
particles in particle physics
where you get to a a transitional thing
that in particle physics might survive
for 10 to the minus 24 seconds
um and then it turns into some final
thing just for my general knowledge in
the chemistry case when there is a
transition state how long does it live
oh they're trans
i would guess they're actually probably
about the same time frame as the
particle physics thing is that right
that short no no it's i think it's i'll
do a second level
i'll do a femto
okay because that minus 24 is a lot but
uh yeah that's what that would be
no it's 10 to the minus 18 to 15.
okay
yeah
and so
that then so so wait a minute are there
are those time scales comparable to
i mean that's shorter than visible light
kind of frequencies
right that's right that's why this
experiment is also difficult to do
to watch this in real time
i see okay but but um
uh
and is it in fact
go ahead what you can observe this with
high harmonics so you get the same one
if you get in the outer seconds range
okay
but but is it in fact the case is a
chemistry general knowledge question
that when a reaction happens that there
are identifiable transition states or is
it just
you know input comes in i mean okay so
at least michael will appreciate i mean
you know where it's just an s matrix
basically some initial states come in
and then final states eventually come
out go ahead for some definitely there
are existing intermediate ones that are
going to identify
so again general knowledge question i
mean in particle physics there'd be
feynman diagrams that would represent a
set of elementary interactions between
things
there's nothing similar in chemistry i
assume
not that universal
but the reason is because in particle
physics there's a lagrangian that says
you know an electron interacts with a
photon and the electron and photon are
both point particles whereas in
chemistry you've got these great big
things
that have a much more complicated you
know where
but explain i mean you've got extended
objects
okay this is now i'm i'm
what is the basic physics of that you
have a hamiltonian for the whole system
but when you have these two big extended
objects you can't think of the
interaction lagrangian
in terms of
is okay it's just too complicated you
could fight down the location no no
problem
you just couldn't enter it
but in particle physics there is a
i think one difference is that in
particle physics each individual
electron
is just
a
a thing in a particular state
whereas in chemistry
you know
the
your hydrogen molecule for example
itself has a whole bunch of internal
degrees of freedom
yep has a lot of states and and
it just get blows up from there when you
deal with typical organic molecules i i
yes but i don't think we have the same
problem in particle physics just we work
with energies where we don't care much
about the bound states if we would do
this at very low energies even qd we
would have the same problems
i see
yeah okay so if you have a bunch of
random positronium atoms interacting
with each other exactly they would show
exactly the same problems
okay fair enough
um all right okay
so
um
uh primaries on the live stream is
commenting about using group theory in
connection with um
uh some of these
i guess pruning of reaction pathways and
so on
and yes presumably that's the case that
i mean it's interesting to think how
that is reflected in the algebraic
theorem proving methods that is
that
i don't think we do that in algebraic
they're improving of saying
uh you can't get there from here
look we can tell that there's a certain
symmetry of this initial tree which
doesn't exist there and so on
yeah and we have to be careful not to
confuse the symmetry of the pathway with
the symmetry of the molecules on it yep
right yep
what does that mean you mean you mean
because the reaction has no it doesn't
care i mean that the molecules have you
might have two symmetrical molecules but
they might interact asymmetrically to
produce an asymmetric molecule exactly
but they also might interact in a way
that you have symmetry along the
reaction path itself
what does that mean so you might have a
mirror so they the the um when the two
molecules come together there might be
symmetry elements there so maybe they
they when they bounce together they
actually have a mirror plane or uh
so you can increase or decrease the
symmetry basically in a reaction yes
yeah
um i mean
needless to say it's the same story in
political physics
um
okay
uh okay so let's go back you were
pointing me to the survey process i
think i understand what's happening here
this is beautiful
um
well bob has a few other examples of
shows
well
how many more hours do you want to stay
on this evening
this is the same graph just without the
events
just showing the molecules no no not the
not the other diels alder examples but
these other two examples this
vogtler
the wagner
yeah that's an example where you start
out with one molecule and it rearranges
and forms a very nice multi-way system
that does terminate
there's there's the first step there uh
the the red atom has a charge these are
renderings they don't look like uh
it's all our stuff
yeah but i mean
why does why does this
just it just looks the fonts look
different than we usually see maybe not
okay well i've labeled the atoms
but okay so then now this
okay so this is our friendly molecule is
that a sulfur atom there no it's it's
the one that has the charge on it oh
okay
so it'd be easy to spot
is that a standard i see that's our
standard highlighting color for the
first yeah
yeah
and that's not the color of a sulfur
atom
no i think sulfur is yellower this looks
more goldy
okay all right okay that's not the color
of a gold atom then
no the gold atom at least won't form a
compound so we don't have to worry so
much about it
um okay all right so that's the molecule
lovely
okay
and and the bonds either hydrogens can
move an adjacent hydrogen can move to
that colored atom
or one of the bonds to a carbon atom can
shift and then
where the bond shifted from the charge
then goes to that atom and so the
example in the uh
token event graph is showing
four different ways that that can happen
okay
and
yeah so they're you know describe the
details there about which bonds are
moving and where the charge is is
shifting to to compensate
the good we don't need any of these
words because we can just see the
picture
yeah i mean that's it i think by the way
in terms of step-by-step chemistry
i'm just curious
if we were to put this interval from
alpha with step-by-step stuff would we
need to generate would it be useful to
generate these kinds of verbal
descriptions of what's going on that
would be the text for each step yeah
yeah pretty much yeah so so with this
technology
could we actually i mean is it a useful
thing to put this into to our
to you know describing reactions in
wolfram alpha is that useful or is that
like like nobody cares my hope would be
that so in the second semester organic
chemistry you start learning reactions
and there's a small set of molecules
that you would feed in as reactants and
a small set of
transformations that correspond to
reactions that they would know at that
point and we should be this is the tools
that i would be able to build
um automated answer keys to those sorts
of things through the step-by-step
machinery that's great and we would have
organic students flocking to this the
way you have high school calculus
students flocking well you already have
lots of rooms you already have lots of
organic chemistries too right but no i
remember those organic synthesis
problems right so uh like i i was i'm a
chemist but like i i like being a
computer programmer really but i'll tell
you what i really like those synthesis
problems it was just like pure logic yep
it was it was nice
basically this is the underlying i mean
just like in the end with stoichiometric
stuff it's different equations and so on
here this is the industrial machine
necessary to solve these kinds of
problems is that a first statement yes
basically your question earlier could
you start from your your center molecule
and the bob's explosion diagram for the
diels-alder and go to a particular
product that's a homework problem start
with this small molecule here's your
three or four different reactions that
you know
what sequence do you have to do to get
to this final product okay that's
a homogram that's organic chemistry
right an orga only i mean
you get that in inorganic too it's a
little a little bit hairier but yeah all
right so then this technology should
allow us to do this great
yeah always you can always expect to
industrialize what was previously done
by lots of hand tricks
yeah okay so now you're going on with
this token event graph right and
after nine steps uh you've exhausted all
the possibilities and uh this layout
here is just the default one you get it
actually starts at the lower left corner
but the next diagram
uh where i've removed
the events it actually is top down from
the first molecule to the next
and going all the way down and the
dashed line represents the the
demarcation between
two groups all the molecules that you
see above the line you will find those
ring systems in natural
terpene molecules they're all formed
biologically and the ones below the line
have not been observed in nature
and this type of rearrangement is used
to produce these
these natural products things like
menthol and camphor and pinene and and
those sorts of things
but so when below the line you get there
by just heating in test tubes and things
but no you would have to do it in yeah
you would have to do it in the in the
laboratory the ones above the line
nature does
okay
so
okay
that's very interesting so this is a
this is a terminating rewrite system it
terminates yep and terminates in that
guy yeah oh no it tell me it's in a
bunch of loops yes there are there are
several leaves on this
okay and some of them are cycles
yes they would be yes yeah
so
let me just understand in terms of these
reactions
when the thing terminates in a cycle
what actually happens in the test tube
so to speak
basically as you put heat in it just
keeps cycling around these different or
or is it the case that these things one
of them is higher energy one is lower
energy and so it will always end up in
one of them
there's that possibility as well yes
but but let's say they're of equal
energy or does that not happen and then
then then is it the case that just keeps
cycling around
if yes if they're of equal energy they
would they would keep reacting back and
forth uh if you've got enough heat going
in
and then when you take the heat away and
it cools down you'd end up with you know
roughly equal amounts of both okay so
can i understand the chemist's version
of entropy
how does that affect these reaction
rates
mostly only in terms of the symmetry i
believe is that right jason s
yes i believe so it would come into the
partition function yeah
yeah
but so what you're saying is that but i
mean the the
that is because of your way of doing
counting that it matters when you talk
about symmetry you're saying you might
generate an equal number of the you know
left and right molecules or some such
other thing
and
that
i mean
well
doesn't don't these reaction pathways
account for quotes entropy that is what
when you have a picture
i mean if we did correct path counting
okay in a picture like this
i believe we're suppressing
are we suppressing the pathways or not
in someone i'm saying that that is there
could be two different ways
to get from one of these to another one
there could be two distinct ways to do
that two distinct matches that would
allow you to get there
oh that makes sense so in other words
you could you could take your original
template and you could do it you know
left to right or right to left
and it might so happen that both of
those give you yes yes in fact if you
look at the bottom left one
here what look like two double paths
going up to two events
and they both go to the same product yes
that one there so it does it two
different ways by shifting different
bonds
okay so in the token event graph we are
correctly accounting for the
possibilities so so when i asked about
entropy
you're saying
that in some sense the rate of
generating events
is some fixed rate but the fact that
there are two events here means that
there will be more of this product than
there would be if there was only a one
event way to get there is that a true
statement
uh
if it was done under kinetic control i
would say yes but if you just put them
in a test tube and heat them for a
period of time it would be thermodynamic
control
and then it would be the the free
energies of the
of the products that would determine the
distribution not the rate at which they
got there because they'd have time to
equip to equilibrate
okay so hold on let me understand that
so what you're saying there is
if these are two-way reactions
then the story is different the thing i
just described at first is the kinetic
case is the case where you're driving it
forwards through those events oh okay
yeah but what you're saying is that
really but i don't see it oh i see there
is a way to go back from here through
that yes yes there is yep okay so so
then this graph
you're saying that in
okay so let me let me just walk through
that for a second so you say in
equilibrium
you've got the forward reaction the
backward reaction
and those reactions have different
reaction rates is that correct
yes they would depending on yeah yeah
because and the reason they have
different reaction rates i mean the
naive reason would be there's an e to
the minus beta h
term
the e e to the minus beta times the
energy difference is that right
or is it something different or how uh
together with
some other entropy related term which i
don't understand it would be the energy
difference between the the ground states
and the transition state yep the barrier
the barrier heights and the barrier
heights would be different depending on
the direction you're going in
unless the
you know the two things happen to be
entered
iso energetic
okay hold on but the the first question
is the difference in energy of the final
ground states
right like like your two molecules here
this this one here
and this one here yeah they would be
different right so we can compute
and and for us
how do we i'm okay naive question if we
compute
the molecular weight
that does not account for that there's
no binding energy the binding energy is
not accounted for in the molecular
weight correct correct
he's adding up atoms this is not nuclei
it's not particle physics the binding
energy is small compared to the masses
of the particles
right okay so the edge of what today can
be
measured on the scale
okay fair enough
but so then
so what is the quantity that gives you
the equivalent of the binding energy
what what's it what's it called in
chemistry i just don't know what it
would be uh the strain energy or the
heat of formation
of a change in change in enthalpy um
between the two species at
0k
and then if you want to get to the free
energy
yeah then you have the t delta s
okay all right let me just walk through
this i i at one point even even okay so
the enthalpy
is the interpretation of the enthalpy is
it's the ground state energies
independent of any temperature terms
is will give you
that that's what determines
is that what that is
one more time
the enthalpy
is it the so in other words you've got
these two molecular species
and they each have a certain binding
energy
and
what how do you what is the chemistry
name for that binding energy
how do i look up the binding energy if i
uh okay i've got this molecule okay this
one here this cyclohexadiene or whatever
it is how do i look up the binding
energy associated with that
information yeah i just say that's the
heat of formation
the chemical yeah so so let me just just
for my actual understanding if i take
this molecule and i say what what is our
name for that
i don't think we compute that at the
moment no we don't and
actually we were just talking about this
last couple weeks ironically
okay but what's the closest
approximation to that i mean what what
it would be the mmf energy
yeah
what does that mean
it's the name of a force field uh that
we have that
can compute
an energy for a set of atoms and bonds
that are bound together
and for the same set you know for the
same number of atoms
uh of the same types
those energies would be comparable to
tell you the relative uh stability of
each of them right okay okay so that is
the ground state energy
okay so now you're telling me the rate
that okay so that's the ground state
energy and
the most naive if i if i was to look at
this in thermal equilibrium
why would
the relative abundances of those not be
exponentials of the difference of ground
state e to the difference of ground
state energy
divided by kt
what the question is because of the
barrier in between
well the barrier in between well it
would depend on what the g you know
what's what's happening to change one
molecule into the other and the pathway
you take to do it there are a lot of
chemically different ways you could
rearrange the atoms and bonds between
those two structures
but hold on
the definition of thermal equilibrium
ultimately is you've got a bunch of
states
and
you know in standard canonical ensemble
world
those states
their relative frequencies are
determined by the boltzmann factor
am i wrong
so why is that not the case for
molecules no it would be and that's just
the the difference in the heats of
formation then
right but so what i was asking is in
equilibrium when you're looking at these
two species
is it or is it not the case that you can
compute the relative abundances of these
things in thermal equilibrium
by just computing e to the minus the
difference of heats of formation divided
by kt
no because you where those yellow dots
are there's an another structure that we
don't have and that will have a certain
amount of energy and that's what's
determining the um
the entropy
okay let me walk through this because in
standard thermal equilibrium you have a
heat bath
and you're imagining
so
i mean this is this is where the
chemistry is not admitting that there's
a
okay i'm a little confused here because
heat
gets into these molecules
by
you know
their
elastic collisions with other molecules
is that a true state right yeah
those yellow things are the inelastic
collisions that are actual reactions
yeah
right so most of the time the vast
majority of interactions are elastic
collisions
that
are simply exciting the molecule
and and could change the internal state
of the molecule but do not change its
its you know overall configuration they
don't constitute
reactions no bond breaking
right and i mean am i correct in
believing
that
uh
you know in a typical chemical situation
the only way that heat the only form of
heat is the motion of molecules there's
no
i mean you know when you heat something
with a bunsen burner for example that is
purely
yeah there's no radiation just adding
kinetic energy to the system yeah right
there's no radiative term there's it's
just pure
it's pure
um
uh kt is what we call it
right but it's it's pure collisions
between between molecules
okay fine all right so then but let me
understand this thing about these
transition states so
in one of these events
you are
imagining that that event happens
by a transition state being formed that
then decays back into that
you know these two molecules come
together they form some complicated you
know
uh transitional
you know cluster
clump which then falls apart again into
two other molecules
that correspond to the results of the
reaction is that the picture yeah or in
in this case
the one molecule goes to the transition
state where you've you've got a bond
that's sort of between two atoms
uh straddling them not settled on one or
the other and then it relaxes
back to the the original atom to which
it was attached to go to the reactants
or forward to the product
okay but so now
you're saying
the thing that's confusing me is
normally in the canonical ensemble all
that matters is the energy of the state
and this business about transitions
between states
in in quotes equilibrium doesn't care
about any of that
because you're assuming
what equilibrium means
in the canonical ensemble with a heat
path i think
it's just that
you're
okay i'm confused here michael
if it's an equilibrium the transition
state really doesn't come into play
unless it's insurmountable
as long as there's enough energy
to overcome that okay fine
the final ensemble will be the row based
on the relative energies of the two
different exactly that's what that's
molecules yeah they might be at
astronomical large times
okay okay so this is the part i want to
understand
in practice in chemistry
it is not sufficient to know the heat of
formation to know the the equilibrium to
know the practical equilibrium
concentrations is that correct
chemistry never really worried i mean
yes
you have a piece of iron and the
equilibrium state is not that it's not
oxidized in front of you
wait a minute the okay but hold on a
second what is the traditional chemistry
version of if i want to work out how
much of this molecule compared to this
molecule i have how do i do that
calculate the heats of formation of each
and use the uh
partition function or the bolt yeah um
the boltzmann factor to calculate them
based on
h
right okay fine i think i understand
that but then that doesn't it doesn't
matter what what the events are between
them in that case
in principle yes yes okay now in
practice what happens
well as michael said if it takes forever
to have that transition happen
the one's not going to go to the other
okay then it's not in equilibrium
that that's right then it won't well
it would be in an equilibrium uh
technically it's not an equilibrium yes
between the two stages
what do chemists say about it
do they call it equilibrium even when it
isn't actually
in you know boltzmann factor ratios
yes they would say it's not at
equilibrium
uh
but
yeah it's just that there's an
insurmountable barrier between the two
okay fine
um
okay
um
universal master for thermodynamic
entropy go ahead but even in physics we
wouldn't say that a neutron is not in
equilibrium because it hasn't decayed
yet
even physics we use this abuse
right i mean in physics okay because the
issue is
different species
equilibrium is not usually a story of
reactions usually i mean equilibrium in
in traditional statistical mechanics
equilibrium is is like we've got a bunch
of you know particles bouncing around in
a box the fact that those particles
might all suddenly break apart
is not something usually consider this
is complicated
right so in
oh i see
um
i mean okay one case of this that i
remember working out long ago was the
early universe case
where
yeah yeah i mean basically
right
it's a little bit of a hack right the
way that you get equilibrium between
different species
which is what you're saying michael
about neutrons
i mean okay in a neutron star this
matters
right you have this
and um
and then you have equilibrium between
okay and then then we have things like
chemical potential what what is the role
okay general knowledge question here the
role of chemical potential in the
discussion of equilibrium for these
kinds of things
is that just a i've got a higher number
density of one kind of species than
another or what
i believe so right jason jason s i was
thinking so the um because it's the
derivative of gibbs energy with respect
to the number of moles yeah with respect
to the number of moles so you're getting
yeah yeah that's that's right that's the
right way to think about it
the okay
okay all right
okay well this is good all right so
let's let's so i think we understand
this this is a terminating rewrite
system
implemented i mean you see one thing
okay so you know the bigger picture here
is molecular computing
and in a sense
what we have here is a graph rewriting
system
so if we can compile
our random computation into graph
rewriting
then in a sense
you know
then if we have the right events in
chemistry
we can compute it in other words in
other words what i mean what to me is
interesting is that normally you know
when i see chemical reactions i don't
normally see
you know things like this
you know normally when i see a chemical
reaction it'll be some pathway and it'll
be some you know set of things you don't
normally see a complicated i don't think
at least you don't normally see
something like this but this makes it
seem a lot more like it could actually
compute something non-trivial or am i am
i getting confused here
i mean to me
this is so in other words if we can
compile
a computation into graph rewriting
into the we've got certain graph
rewritings that we can do which
correspond to the events that we can
implement chemically
then the question is
if
we can
compile
you know
given those okay what what
okay the thing that's a little confusing
relative to like a turing machine is
we're a little bit more controlled or we
seem
a little bit more controlled in a turing
machine or in a
or in a
a expression rewriting system because
we've got this tree in a definite order
here
what do we have what what is our input
here our input is
uh
well
how do we determine the input other than
by
just saying we've got these chemicals in
these concentrations
if that makes sense like like for a
in in the case of an expression a
combinator expression let's say
or let's take a combination expression
as an example
we imagine that the input is you know s
of k of s of s of s of whatever it is
right we've got this long essentially
combinator
polymer
okay
and our long combinator polymer
is the initial condition and it goes
crunch crunch crunch and does all these
reactions so to speak
and then comes out with a result
yeah okay so my question would be
what would we imagine that if we just
think about things in liquid phase
chemistry which is i guess what this
mostly is is that right i mean these
these reactions are mostly liquid phase
yeah
yeah
um
so
you know
what's the preparation of an initial
state in liquid phase chemistry in other
words if for example
we were able to
let's imagine that we could let's
imagine that we could make
a
graph transformation that actually is
the combinator reduction
it doesn't seem totally impossible that
one could do that
right so in other words we've got to
have something where you know
k x y
and well i don't mean you know i don't
mean a potassium there i mean the k
combinator right but who knows what the
k combinator you know the k combinator
might actually be
some little you know residue type thing
um
together with two
you know slots
two arbitrary connections
x and y
you know and then basically we would
have an event reaction where it turns
into
x or whatever
i mean that would be that would be how
we would implement a combinator
chemically but the question would be if
we want to prepare the initial state how
would we do that
in other words if you want to just make
a molecule so so i mean you know clearly
in biology we've got ribosomes and
things like that that go and extrude
molecules
is that the only known way to kind of
custom make
i mean this is this is sort of the
problem of ultimate molecular
manufacturing how do you make an
arbitrary molecule but we're not asking
for an arbitrary molecule we're asking
for something that is extruded a bit
like a ribosome extrudes things
potentially
how can you how can you make a molecule
whose structure
is specified programmatically
other than with biology
there's just a nature paper about it
from u of a people today
okay
what does it say i haven't read it yet
okay but it's some heteropolymer type
thing
no it's smaller but it makes things we
couldn't do before is this the one with
the bowl and the pharisees
i don't know
okay and then i'm thinking
let me find it yeah you'll send it
around right michael
i think i sent this morning
um
okay but but then i hope my mom might
have a male 1 was just sending it to
because i don't remember seeing that but
then i wouldn't necessarily know yet
um
okay but but
but you see where i'm where i'm going
with this one so the question is can we
prepare an initial state because having
a bunch of
molecules of you know molecules just
floating around based on their
concentration is not going to be enough
to specify the initial conditions for a
computation
it might be enough to have these
molecules kind of
i don't know you know if we have some
kind of chemical observer
that's kind of arranging molecules on a
membrane or something okay so here's
another question i mean in
is the right thing to do to try and
imagine assembling a molecule which then
in liquid phase has things happened to
it or is the right thing to do to try
and assemble a molecule on a surface
and have things happen to it
if you wanted to very controlled then
the surface would be the way to go or
some other kind of matrix
okay what's an example of where you
assemble a molecule on a surface or in a
matrix
perhaps
forming a crystal of something and then
irradiating it and the bonds happen to
be in the right juxtapositions that they
rearrange
and form you know new bonds between the
molecules
well okay so for that
the other project that i my random
crystals project is relevant that is can
you get a set of things which arrange
themselves in a okay so so what you're
saying is
which i think seems very difficult
that is
if you have the right
matching conditions you can end up with
something
that um
[Music]
uh
um
the um
um
i think an example would be that penta
diamond paper that came out a year and a
half ago
but there are pathways which take a long
time which takes like days right look at
what you need for making the vaccine i
mean they need days for certain
reactions to happen
what was the thing there what what's the
point there
other other conditions which you have to
consider it's not just i mean you cannot
solve these things from first principle
it's a that's why chemists the chemical
industry is such a big thing because
they they they have to find these things
but if you look how they do the vaccine
i mean they take reactions it takes
weeks to to do right
which reaction takes weeks
there are certain certain ways how they
prepare the the the
uh
vaccines
but but which part of it the liquid
nanoparticle part or the not the rna
part but some parts stay taken quite a
long time that's why it takes long to
develop
it took so long
well vaccines that are
killed vaccines or partially killed
vaccines they have to grow them
and they get produced inside you know
the virus gets produced inside the host
cell and ex and uh well i don't think
it's that because they said
certain chemical reactions would take
days or weeks to that's why
that has to be the coat not too i would
think i mean otherwise
well whatever yeah i mean if you if you
apply heat to make it go faster you
probably end up denaturing things and
that's why they have to do it at room
temperature or colder
and then it's slow
um but but chemistry so i mean
that's why the chemistry chemical
industry is really a big big industry
right and and
it's not that i mean
solving is from first principles i think
it's a little bit naive picture here so
well
the software industry is a big industry
too i mean it doesn't mean that you
can't make up
a um you know you can't and you can't
have combinators that can do all of
software
but there are certain companies which
which went through the literature and
collected all the uh chemical reaction
published and now they're using this for
synthesis and they're selling products
i'm well aware i know that's been a long
running you know that that's been a
thing which people have tried to do
since the 1960s when the first
applications of automated theorem
proving to chemistry were done
now hold on hold on stephen you're
making a comment about molecular
computing a while ago and then you asked
this question about the initial
condition how do these
go together but what i'm saying is if we
could construct the initial condition
then
could it be the case
that
i mean this
is like a quantum computation we've got
exactly the same problem we've got a
whole bunch of pathways here which are
computing a whole bunch of things in
parallel yes and we've got to figure out
what's the answer well this is just a
reaction code it's like an entailment
cone yes but for chemistry
yes that's right but the point is that
the observer here exactly the same type
of problem as with quantum mechanics
you know let's say this was factoring
let's say this was computing products of
numbers okay and we want to find out uh
let's say we had something here and that
would be an amusing case to look at in
which we've got an encoding of numbers
in these molecules and we're computing
the um you know each one of these parts
is a different product of numbers okay
fine and so
somewhere here is the number one two
three four seven or something that we
want to find the factors of
okay and the factors will correspond to
the path
that gets to this
yes yeah okay so now
go ahead
i don't
i missed to see that the quantum
mechanical part is there's definitely an
analogy no no michael that's a classical
classical field the whole thing is a
classical system this is the classic
good good so it has zero non-trivial
effects
yes the h bar is zero here okay okay h
bars i mean we don't have entanglement
on any of the interesting things in the
world
well let's take a look at that i'm not i
think this graph is interesting michael
i'm not certain that we don't have
entanglement we don't have quantum
entanglement
but we have a different kind of
entanglement
hold on hold on stephen you were saying
we want to find a particular we want to
find out
so let's say we're trying to solve the
problem we're trying to use chemistry to
factor a number okay
so we put in our you know our our
molecules they compute all these
different possible paths yes one of
those parts
correctly generates the number we want
and we say look this is a factoring of
that number okay okay the problem that
we have is there are many paths
and to find the one that we care about
is not trivial yes so in chemical
synthesis
what one would say is the yield you know
normally we would say
there's lots of detail that we have to
put in to increase the yield right we
don't want all this other stuff here
this is you know as we run this thing
most of the molecules most of the
reactions happening in our test tube are
irrelevant because the one that we want
is just this one that's going to make
that particular molecule
right so we could if we were doing
synthetic chemistry we could spend a lot
of effort increasing the yield that
would lead to that particular molecule
we want
but the reason i'm making an analogy
with uh you know with quantum mechanics
is at least qualitatively in a sense
when we have a quantum computer the
concept of what's going on
is that we are you know we're following
all these paths
and they're all happening in parallel
which is exactly the same as what's
happening here
no i'm still not convinced it would be
like the factoring algorithm you do with
light and gratings you have a classical
one that you
can follow
you're allowed to look inside in between
which you couldn't do in quantum
mechanics
okay but what if you have what if you
have some physicalized observer not
necessarily a membrane but something
like it that could provide some
indication
you know when the path that we're
looking for is being you know passed
through that
you know that's physicalized yeah
there's some sieve at the end
um
and um
you know
and that's and when the thing falls
through the you know the sieve then you
know it's the answer
the problem is it's non-trivial to make
that sieve i
claim and i claim that that's the analog
i'm not completely certain of this but i
claim that there is a potential analog
of that problem in the can you look
inside problem that is that as soon as
that sieve
could by mistake sieve something in the
middle here you're kind of toast you
can't get all the way to that answer
michael if that made sense
in other words
you've got a thing that is trying to
observe stuff here
and can you make an observer that
doesn't mess with the stuff inside here
but only gets it only nails it when it
gets to an answer
well the other point is that if the
sieve
is being placed at some parent node
the the pathways are still ramifying so
that's
you can't put it there
well i know but
look physically there's a bunch of
molecules bouncing around liquid
yes i understand
that so
you know the way that we measure them is
ultimately well what how might we
measure them i mean what we might do
for example let's say we had a um and i
don't know my
my
what is it i don't know a lysa thing or
whatever the heck those things are those
things where you have a little attached
what are those things called where you
have um uh attached little peptides
that um on a plate and then things bind
to them
what is that
that's eliza i believe
yeah okay fine
the okay but i mean so so that would be
an example here of where we've got those
little things hanging off of you know
off the side of our test tube we have a
bunch of little you know attached
peptides and then you know when we've
got the right answer we bind to those
you know the right answer molecules bind
to those little hanging peptides and
then we take the thing out and we we do
um
uh you know we measure it without with
some ultraviolet light or something okay
okay so that will be an example of what
uh you know of the workflow here that is
we put the things in
we have to prepare the initial
conditions which i don't understand how
to do
we heat the thing up it does all the
things it's going to do
then
we have our little place where
you know we we have we stick into this
test tube a little thing which has all
these little attached binding things on
it we pull that out we see whether
anything bound to it
that's our experiment so to speak so we
try to get an answer so the thing is in
terms of the meta models the initial
conditions obviously it's not confusing
at all right i mean you can just causal
graph branchial graph we know what the
initial condition is are you saying
methodologically in terms of a lab it's
more difficult yeah i'm saying i have no
idea how to make the initial condition
in a lab
okay okay that's
because i think the initial condition
has to be a configuration of molecules
or a particular molecule
in other words if i took this picture
and
instead of that starting with a very
simple molecule here i would start with
some kind of heteropolymer thing
and then have all these reactions
happening on that
that will be a case where i can give
input like i can give the initial
combinator and then it's going to do a
bunch of reductions and the reductions
will correspond to the multi-way graph
that represents all possible evaluation
paths for the combinator yes and then
the issue is what is the answer you know
how do i sieve the thing to get the
particular answer that i want now in the
case where the thing terminates it's
fairly easy right in the case where it's
confluent it's fairly easy because all
if it's terminating and confluent
then it's all easy then in the end you
just keep heating the you know you start
off with your initial combinator
molecule you keep keeping it up and
stirring it and whatever else and in the
end you've got this white powder left
over and that thing is your answer
foliations and the observer really they
don't matter for something that's
completely confluent yes but i mean that
that's that was the case where you had
except for the fact you had multiple
final states in your in your example
wherever it was
in your example where in this example
here you have
ultimately but the difference here is
you have multiple final states
right you have in this picture in the
physics terminology you have closed time
like curves here
you've got molecules that are cycling
around
as opposed to
it's just a partial order and in the end
you get a single molecule out
there's there's no
the notion of time
is not recognizable in this picture
because you have cycles
um
yeah yeah and there are related systems
to this where everything ends up being
just one molecule in the end you can
start with almost anything and let it go
and because of the stability of
of the one particular molecule in the
network everything ends up there no no i
want to see an example of that that
would be really nice to see that it's
adamantane rearrangements
or diamantain
you have that's one of the i don't have
that coded up yet that's what i want to
do next okay but fine but you're saying
that purely combinatorially
all roads lead to the same answer there
it doesn't require anything about um you
know
energies of transition states or
anything like that no because the the
reaction conditions are such that all
those barriers are overcome
wow that's cool i don't i want to see
that that's a that's a chemical black
hole
i mean it you know effectively yes yes
i can send you some some publications
from the uh
70s and 80s that we're looking into that
okay all right let's take a look at some
of the other things that are here
um
yeah let's go to james's stuff
okay
boy i'm impressed that james knows
anything about chemistry i'm i'm
okay well wolfram alpha certainly helps
you're welcome
yeah thanks thanks guys
okay
so
you are trying to make
okay
what is that is that used for fertilizer
or something what is that
i have no idea bob why do we want soda
why are we doing this in the first place
what do we want to ask uh it was just
somebody at one of our previous meetings
questions but i might say why are we
doing this i mean why did this solve a
fellow even decide to you know do this
why do we want soda ash
why is it uh
uh
that uh
okay which one is this the soda ash is
is uh sodium carbonate
um probably is a way to produce sodium
carbonate uh that would be used as
reagent and you know some other chemical
process
to be able to get it from some starting
material
um actually i looked this up here it
says soda ash has a number of
diversified uses that touch our lives
every day yeah glass manufacturing is it
for baking this is for baking cooking
food additives well usually it's the
bicarbonate form
that's got uh
you need it for pretzel you have to uh
you need it for pretzels yeah you you
can't you you have to print the uh paint
the pretzel otherwise it will not get
the nice
okay well this is this is important
obviously if pretzels depend on it yeah
i don't know the brexit the brexit you
get for the both side you know the one
the big one
okay so let's
okay
so this is sodium chloride and calcium
carbonate
yes
and we end up getting soda ash and
calcium chloride okay so what sort of
the underlying rules here all the ones
up top
the tons of them there are a lot
especially when you specify them all in
detail there are many rules
okay and this is the fully deduplicated
graph
well okay technical question for nick so
nick your three settings right now
for these token event graphs right you
have token deduplication true
false and none so this is false
what's the difference between false and
none that that option for the tags right
now
so false means you only duplicate
on each time slice and none you
basically oh did duplicate the crossover
duplicate not not at all yeah you just
add a unique index to each token okay
so this is duplicate this is
deduplicated
goes to false
for the so that means there are two
sodiums here right so at different time
steps so if we de-duplicate it all the
way
so if we open this up i don't know
whether we can do this here and we do
duplicate it all the way
then we would only have one sodium now
correct yes i had some problems with
that deduplication though which is why
well how do we set that yeah it's just
token deduplication if you just go up to
the right to the right
right there yeah
yeah you want complete de-duplication
well but it's not going to work because
the highlighting
when you have it uh as
token deduplication goes to false you
specify the tokens in a different way
when you do that
the highlighting is wrong but the the
final output
yeah so i don't quite understand what
this is doing so this is saying we get
as output
calcium chloride yes
and ammonia no and soda ash but this
that's not so dash i know
look at the arrows arrows are going up
this layout is
this oh yeah all right so let's say
graph of this
um graph layout goes to
uh layered digraph embedding
nope
that's still doing the same thing but so
yeah
and what on earth why on earth is that
h2 italic very weird
that's weird that's a small bucket
it's a single letter before the
subscript and that's why it gets
italicized whereas in carbonate you've
got co before you see the subscript but
what about with the
okay anyway there's a minor bug in h3
that's kind of weird
anyway
it's because it's nh it's two letters
two letters
it's not two atoms it's two letters okay
okay yeah okay so
okay so what are we learning from this
so this is
a thing where if we included pathways
we would get
i believe the
whole no okay explain the
okay
if we wanted stoichiometry we would have
to do something where we
like a petri net we consider
different kinds of um
what petri nets called tokens and how
that flows through this graph i mean
this would be a petri net if i'm not
mistaken if we actually put
uh
you know constant amounts on each node
am i right about that i think so you
know
okay
so
it's essentially a
d
stoichiometrized petri net whatever that
might be called
um
okay but that's cool sub sub chemistry
petri net it's a subchemistry pattern
yes where where it doesn't care about
the total concentrations it just cares
about what the molecules actually do
what without the rules
okay so what's this what are these
colored lines here well so you know the
overall reaction is
you know sodium chloride plus calcium
carbonate goes to
soda ash and calcium chloride so i want
to have arrows between the left-hand
sides and the right-hand sides of this
reaction
so you have your paths from calcium
chloride
going to soda ash and also going to
calcium sorry you have it from sodium
chloride going to calcium chloride and
soda ash you also have your paths going
from
calcium carbonate to those two outputs
as well but it seems to me that
while we talk about a single reaction
path this is more like the matter
mathematical case but what we really
want just like in the meta mathematical
case
we didn't
you know
in the end
to prove a theorem
we end up with a whole
you know past light cone
that contains certain inputs
and then puffs out into a bunch of of
you know simultaneous lemmas yes and
then comes back down to the final state
i'm just calling those reaction cones
yes right okay but but now are we seeing
a reaction cone here or are we seeing
we're seeing i mean this is much it's
well it's kind of much dirtier than that
because what we had in meta mathematics
is we had two-way rules and so the
kernels as i call them like the cores of
those entailment cones were you know it
could just be one two-way rule for
instance whereas here i have to specify
many many
many rules in order to to get this
industrial process to work
so it's not a kind of a clean
uh reaction pathway that kind of just
takes care of itself it seems i have to
specify many rules to get this to work
so i don't think it's a good i don't
think it's a good example of what we
want in terms of a reaction this is an
engineering example
where i mean this thing if you just kept
it running right that this if i ran this
for another step nothing else would
happen is that a true statement no i
think you keep knowing it keeps going
well let's see it yeah
that's so if i do this
and i go
where's the number is that fourth order
and this of course doesn't have its full
deduplication
but it's is it going to make any other
species
no
okay so if it was fully de-duplicated in
the test tube nothing turns green or
whatever you know it's not like
eventually there's some weird other
compounds there's no surprises no
right but
that's because of the way that these
rules have been specified right because
it's not i'm it's not like i'm doing
bond atom pattern matching i'm just
specifying these molecules i get it
right but my point is this is
traditional engineering in the sense
that the thing has been heavily
constrained so they can really only do
one thing that's right right okay so i
claim
that the two examples that we have well
we have only one example right now the
only example we have molecular computing
is life
and
quite possibly life is making use of
things which are not as deeply
constrained as this
um or maybe it did at the beginning at
least
um and what we want for
you know the interesting case of
molecular computing
is the case where where you really can
do this this kind of elaborate stuff but
you really can get it to um you know
to
to do that number of computations it is
not the case where in the engineering
situation where you've optimized the
synthesis pathway and you've put all
these protecting groups on to stop stop
different side paths happening and so on
and you have most of the action going on
a single pathway
that's exactly what we don't want we
want something where you can do
more like sort of the promise of quantum
computing where you can you know do a
lot of things in parallel i think yes
well and also we want to be able to
capture computational work which will be
irreducible
and
i don't think we should put that many
constraints on it but the difficulty is
going to be the observer theory question
especially if as you said before the
kind of fundamental objects of these
computations will be paths rather than
individual tokens
how to be able to capture you know
irreducible computational work from
these
using some observer theory technologies
without always being able to anticipate
what those paths would be like well okay
okay but one possibility is the answer
is the molecule you make
rather than the answer is the journey by
which you get there yeah well okay but
that's kind of different from what i
know it's different from what we've
discussed before i mean what we've
discussed before is
in
a
um
is what kind of information is contained
in the path structure
right so one type of information is what
molecule got made
so where did you end up in metachemical
space
yes right or um and the other is
uh
you know
what path did you follow and by the way
i mean i assume there are judi sick and
non-jdc parts there must be i mean there
clearly are because you can clearly in a
lot of these reactions you can clearly
cycle around forever before you end up
getting to the thing you want to get to
i mean there's a geodesic path
from the initial state to the final
states which is the minimum length
synthesis pathway
am i right
yeah that would yeah i mean you should
be able to find a minimum path between
your your starting note and your desired
final load yes right of not the most
efficient query right
it's not necessarily the most efficient
but i mean in
in practice i'm sure that the
you know one could yes i mean the yield
may be lower for some random reason
right um well it depends on which
reactions you allow and in this you know
this case here there's only one kind
um so
efficiency and yield all depend on what
rules you allow
all right let's take a look what other
things have people got to show here
jason has some stuff ah
oh wow what are these
what are these creatures you know all
these names and and the fact that we
even don't recognize them as has anybody
cross-checked between
our molecule names and our spell checker
that sounds like that i don't think so i
would just say
in the time that i've been here the
chemistry team hasn't thought about that
we should we should you should
communicate with the spell-checking team
because i mean we might as well it's
silly those those words are hardly close
to any other words nobody's going to
make a typo for one of those things that
they should be added to the dictionary i
would think
okay so what is this creature
so this is a
molecule that nature makes to move iron
from the environment to the inside of
the cell okay
and this is a there's a whole family of
these but this is a circular one and it
has you know a symmetric shape as that
first plot shows and then here's the
two of you know another plot showing the
same structure it's a different
conformer of it
uh and then here's the 3d representation
to help where does the iron go does the
iron get stuck in the middle here
somewhere yeah the iron gets stuck in
the middle and we'll see that just a
little bit
and so if you open up the
um the next bullet
so therefore complexation reactions yeah
there you go so here's the iron version
so iron with six waters around it and it
reacts with the big thing and you get
the structure that you see there
so these are all this is all covalent
bonding story
that's right and so what's interesting
here is how you just you're displacing
all those waters and you're removing two
three hydrogens from the big uh seder
four and the question is how do all
these bonds form
there's a variety of different ways that
it could happen
and is this i see this is where
plutonium is substituted for the iron or
something
so there's the iron on top and now
here's the plutonium it has nine waters
rather than six and then if you scroll
down a little further
what is the valence of plutonium
uh in this case it's uh nine coordinate
okay
okay
um
is that i mean again naive question is
that obvious from the periodic table if
you saw where plutonium was would it be
obvious that this would be a
not necessarily that's the problem when
you get past carbon you can have
coordination numbers from 2 to 16.
explain what why well in the case of the
metal here you've got uh f and d
orbitals that can hold electron density
and so each of these water molecules is
dumping electron density from the lone
pairs on the water
into the into the orbitals of the metal
and so you can have configurations where
you have you know in this case we have
nine uh other metals will have more if
you have uh different ligands besides
water
so so are you telling me that the whole
valence theory thing only works for s
and p orbitals
pretty much that that's a
valence bond
oh no yeah yeah it's a very particle
oriented picture of a uh
of an object of the electron which is
you know both on both a particle and a
wave
so wait a minute
you're saying as soon as you get into
the these higher orbitals
where there are more possible electron
configurations
that
that you
that there are many different ways in
which you can do covalent bonding
in which in which the in other in other
words what you're saying is
that
in the in the s p orbital case
that you know if you think about the
orbitals in terms of spherical harmonics
or something they're just you know they
just have sort of two knobs on them or
something they have a small number of of
knobs but whereas what you're saying is
when you get to higher harmonics
then
you can
essentially have the covalent bonding
happen
in many of the different so in other
words if you plot the orbital um you can
have
the places where there is
high
quantum amplitude or something as a
function of angular position you can say
you can
you can have
you can kind of fit
the covalent bonding you can fit the
exchanged electron into many different
kind of holes in the angular
distribution of the i'm i'm not saying
this very well did that make any sense i
mean you did and you're in you're right
and if we were to look at the f like so
uh p orbitals have two lobes these get
up to five or excuse me uh four
um and then so you can get those lobes
then become if you will houses for a
pair of electrons to interact with
each other
and then you can have various linear
combinations i was just going to say can
i like one shouldn't take the slopes too
serious
because there's no reason to assume
nature diagonal is h squared as set
this is nice for convenience but natural
might well diagonalize uh in parabolic
coordinates where we have 30 different
quantum numbers right
i see so so you're saying that the i
mean
the
the question of what the actual states
of the atoms are and this relates also
to the sort of continuous measurement of
atoms and things there's no reason to
think that the eigenstates correspond to
that the thing is in correspond to these
convenient cartesian
or the eigenstate is fine for age but
what physical reason would the molecule
have to because energy cannot be created
and taken away but why should a set be
diagonalized no i that but i mean when
you decompose
the
when you you have an energy you have a
normally in a magnetic field or
something you would split
those different things right yeah um
but without magnetic field that
degenerates we should allow a bit of a
superposition rather than randomly
selected
cartesian-ish thing yeah right well
actually it doesn't it's a spherical
tensor i suppose but i see so
but but the point that i was making is
my understanding is in the sort of
quantum theory of chemistry
you imagine that the the molecule is
somehow in an eigen state
because it is being somehow continuously
measured by the environment that is
that's why we can draw a picture of what
the you know otherwise we would have no
way to validly draw one of these
diagrams with the atoms in particular
positions because they actually
not quite okay yeah
okay so it is an eighteen state because
of energy conservation it is in a
localized
version because of continuous
measurement
otherwise the tent of mass would slowly
flow apart
okay hold on in in an s orbital for
example you know in in
in you know j equals zero the thing is
going to be spherical except that we
might very well draw
our
you know after after separation of
variables
okay fair enough fair enough that is the
critical point the tender of mass part
would normally flow apart but the center
of my spot gets measured continuously by
the infrared field and collapses
so wait a minute let's say we've got a
hydrogen molecule okay
then then there is a
are you saying
that there's a
uh a j equals zero configuration of the
hydrogen atom a hydrogen molecule
that would normally have
but you're saying when we separate the
variables for the two hydrogen atoms
yes
we get internal degrees and external
decrease and normally we totally forget
about the external ones but the wave
function for the external will not be
staying localized why would it
without the external fields
wait a minute you're saying that the x
yes right i mean it's it's
well you're saying why would the
hydrogen molecule be in a particular
orientation no right no no
simplest one just take one hydrogen
atom so we have the
electron and we have the proton in the
middle the first thing what we do is we
go to a coordinate system that's the
tenth of mass system and then we
typically forget about the center of
mass part and just do the relative one
and the redevelop different gives us
then bound states but still we need some
kind of wave function for the center of
mass part and this is free because
it's not
bound by anybody and this one would
unfortunately slowly flow apart
what do you mean by flow apart i mean
the thing it can be anywhere in space
the height i don't know like that the
free evolution of of a particle
uh flows apart
what do you mean by flows apart
initially it's gaussian you wait and the
gaussian has a bigger halflist
in the schrodinger equation yeah
because it's the diffusion-like equation
yes
uh what's that what's the time scale for
that happening
what's the effect of diffusion cons it's
it's a complex diffusion constant right
or imaginary diffusion constant yes
four small things pretty small
but it's ih bar
you know equals i mean that the um
so it's something like the de bruy
wavelength
what is it it's some we should be able
to work this out but what what is the
thing that determines you're
so it's a de bruy time effectively the
boy frequency yeah has to be what
determines the the um the diffusion
constant yes
okay so and and that de bruy frequency
for a typical atom is what
um we must both know alpha must know
this tiny fraction of
seconds
okay but so that means that what you're
saying is
that
on you're saying a gaussian wave packet
will be
you you try to localize the atom yes but
soon the atom will have uh will no
longer be localized just by virtue of
the of the schrodinger equation of the
tenth of mass part
yes right
okay
so that means the atom is fuzzed around
yeah and then how does that affect
and you're saying given that but this
doesn't happen because the infrared
field permanently measures the zinc
okay so normally you're saying
the hydrogen atom would just be sort of
it would i see so you're saying i've got
a picture my ball and stick model of a
molecule but in fact one of my balls
would gradually just diffuse away
were it not continuously measured
the whole thing is no not a part of it
the whole
because the internal ones are all
basically the internal degrees of
freedom of proper bound states with
finite localization it's the whole thing
that is not
fixed
but that's
just its position why can't i
no it's not it's precision it doesn't
move it just spreads out
okay you're saying that the amplitude
i see what you're saying you're saying
that the whole thing
right i get it the whole thing just sort
of uh uh
diffuses away in in amplitude space it
gets thinner and thinner and
bigger and bigger okay so now but what
you're saying is
that that is effectively continuously
measured yeah
and that
walk me through that so you're saying
there's a is it a photon field or is it
we think it's the infrared field
basically
why isn't it i mean it's in practical
matter in chemistry there's a high
collision frequency between them
does that also do i was thinking on a
single one in in vacuum
yes in of course the environment is
extremely efficient in
localizing and measuring
okay so you're saying that
this
that even in a vacuum
that
that okay so there's photon absorption
photon re-emission
why does that
explain why that does anything
i mean in other words because because
basically it is not an isolated system
yes
so the trading equation was a wrong
assumption from the beginning
but but can one actually compute i mean
so let's let's imagine that you turn up
the heat so to speak
from the environment you increase the
dens the photon density in the
environment
is there a measurable way to see that
there is sort of more
more measurement more more maintenance
of localization in other words if you
turn down the heat
so there are very very few photons
do you start is there a way to measure
the delocalization of the
atoms
i don't think so because i think there's
always enough infrared available
to
get everything collapsed
that's very i mean
so you're claiming
that as a practical matter
even in the darkest places i mean forget
the cosmic microwave background
but assume you put it in a box so
there's no cosmic microwave background
you're saying there is no box quiet
enough right that you get delocalization
right
interesting claim
and
but so why do we see quantum mechanics
at all
if that's happening why isn't everything
always being measured all the time
you're saying it is being measured but
the time scale for measurement
is still long compared to the time scale
for other small quantum effects correct
like the time scale it stays for the
moon or something like this
time scale for what is days sorry for
the moon to flow apart
yeah i understand but the time scale
uh
i need to understand this more i need to
understand as the context of our models
this is a james this would be a good
thing to talk to xerxes about he might
have thought about this
yes um okay
i i want to understand this because i
think that we should be able to
understand this with some clarity in
terms of our multi-way graphs and so on
this would be a good good thing to see
why
i mean
summer school student project
too hard too hard
they're too big
uh research affiliate project
yes possibly
i mean
this
what what you effectively seem to be
saying michael
is that
i mean that there's an analogy like in
our models you know
space-time is knitted together by
continual interactions
you're effectively saying i think
i mean
the implication is that objective
reality is knitted together by these
continual interactions
yeah
i think that's a correct statement
how lovely
i mean that that
that would imply
you know in the world of our multi-way
graphs and all these kind of branchial
space things that's a rather lovely idea
that that in other words that the
existence of space
is a consequence of
of um
yeah okay i need to understand this but
this this sounds very cool all right but
this is irrelevant to our chemistry how
do we get talking about this in the
context of the chemistry we were talking
about oh we're back to orthodox yeah
orbitals right okay i was trying to
understand orbitals yeah we were moving
from a valence bond picture
where you're counting eight electrons to
a molecular orbital picture here and the
molecular orbitals are actually an
approximation to the electron density
okay
and that's where we have that often okay
that that's where we where we zoomed off
into into quantum measurement okay so
this this skill cage allows one to
capture an iron or capture a plutonium
is that the basic picture the idea yep
okay so what i was interested in is the
how how it how does all those bonds form
when you bring the two together and
that's what we were looking at and this
sets you up for
a case where you have a metal in this
case iron with water and you're looking
at all the diff you have these small
reactions and are they happening
where you're forming two bonds at once
are you looking at the case where you
have one bond at a time
again look you can map that all out so
did you make the multi-weight graph
someplace here no i did not um
okay but you think you you think you can
and it's going to show a bunch of
reaction pathways
and is there some way using nmr or
something like that where you can
measure
the different you know
different configurations of what happens
or is that how it what can you
that's the tricky part i i don't have a
good answer for you on that one
is it the case when you have these
things where there's a sort of
distinguished atom knocking around am i
am i right to think that nmr is a
potential technique for seeing the
environment of that atom and so on
to a degree
uh but with the metal atom present
that's going to
probably broaden all the signals in an
nmr spectrum
i see because the nmr is primarily
looking at hydrogens
well you know or depending on on the
magnetic field and the frequency the
radio frequency that you're using it
could be looking at carbons or nitrogens
or oxygens
but hydrogen and carbon are the two most
common ones but you can't like tune it
to iron or plutonium
i mean it depends on the the there
obviously is a nuclear magnetic moment
of plutonium for example
yeah it depends on their spin also i
think oh yeah absolutely right
right i mean it is the it's the bore
magneton
right it's the analog yeah there it is
times the spin right it's the h bar
times the spin the
um
but well it's interesting i mean so so
okay look the basic bottom line here as
we
zoom back okay so we basically seem to
understand more or less
how to make token event graphs for
chemistry
um yes
we
it would be nice as a piece of sort of
uh gravy or something to be able to
actually try and use almost theorem
proving to find
um you know pathways here
just yeah just because that would be the
analog of synthetic chemistry so to
speak yes very much so yeah yeah
um
but so then
uh and we don't understand how to get
rate constants and those are really hard
so we're not you know so in a case where
we might try to do molecular computing
we have to have a case where for
whatever reason all the rate constants
are non-zero and we think they're
comparable and we're not worrying too
much about them
uh because if we had to compute them all
right um i mean that that's a no that's
an actual chemistry question whether we
can find that
but then the question is wait wait how
how common or uncommon are those bob
james i mean so like in this big picture
that you had at the top here
would it be the case that most of those
pieces actually happen
up here
do mostly uh
probably the the first
two
probably a lot of the third uh tier
could be made
the fourth tier um
some of them might not be able to be
made because of of
geometry and stuff like that where
you can't get the parts close enough
together to add a new piece
yeah i'd have to look at some of them
more closely they're just too small to
see to see where the double bonds are
um
okay but so so
you know one of the questions is going
to end up being
in
i mean because that would be
in order to do non-trivial computations
we're going to need eventually long
chains of of uh
chemical processes
and
you know
in the case of biology
it's using
i mean
i i would assume it's using enzymes as
its way of kind of just making stuff
happen
you know as its way of catalyzing
these long
chains of reactions is that right pretty
much yeah
and so
for us
in these i mean you know we think these
are liquid state reactions that we're
looking at here
as opposed to sort of enzyme state where
the thing is aligning itself you know
or as opposed to a
you know a solid catalyst or something
where it's effectively a surface
effect
i mean so my question would be if we
want to do something that involves a
long chain of reactions what's the best
way to do it liquid phase probably isn't
going to make it
that true statement
i mean because you're saying
in the liquid phase
it's too easy to get molecules that
flop around
and prevent sort of
you know fail to expose the places where
actual reactions could happen
yeah that could be part of it also some
of them you know
in this graph here if you look at the
ones on the periphery
they're getting big enough that they
might not be very soluble anymore and
therefore would would uh
form a tar on the bottom of the flask
and wouldn't be available for reaction
that way no i love that this is you know
we're
at some level
we're doing mathematics or computation
but in the end
the thing precipitates out and makes it
hard that's right yeah
um we've got to work i mean if you want
to reduce this to practice in the lab
you know those those are considerations
absolutely yes this is what i'm
expecting this is why i actually want to
run some of these things in emerald's
infrastructure and see what happens but
okay so what does it mean
okay
what makes something not soluble
what makes something what makes
something soluble
okay explain it's too heavy dude that's
too big
yeah to be insoluble um
that uh it sticks to to other copies of
itself
and uh well so it solidifies the thing
effectively yeah it might not be
crystalline but
you end up getting a particle and and
more stuff accretes to the surface
what's the difference in a tar and a
glass
atar is probably a soft glass
okay so it's just some amorphous you
know
amorphous
yeah yeah mess
okay all right so
so you're saying that the issue is
that
at a certain temperature
the
the longer the molecule the less soluble
it's going to be is that right
and that therefore when the molecule is
big
well no what you're saying when that
when if because the temperature is
higher the molecules will presumably get
broken apart or am i that could be that
could also be an issue yeah
i see the molecule actually you know
decompose
but you know i was thinking of what
would cause the thing to not precipitate
out as a tar
um
well basically the interactions between
the solvent molecules and the new
molecules you've made have to be um
those interactions have to be if you
will exothermic so that the
or more favored
than than the molecule making covalent
or making you know van der waals
interactions with itself and starting to
form a solid yeah
okay what's the temperature dependence
of that likely to be
or is that not obvious i don't think
it's not obvious to me but as the
molecules thought about valence i've
never thought about the temperature
dependence of a van der waals
interaction
yeah i guess you could think about it as
it's in the same realm as the
temperature dependence of a hydrogen
bond in some bio thing
yeah but in van der waals interaction is
just
i mean
as i understand that from the at least
from the quantum electrodynamics point
of view which might not be the chemistry
point of view that's i mean it's some
vacuum fluctuation
it has a produces a temporary dipole
moment which then uses a dipole moment
in the other molecule and that's how you
get the
fully the hydrophobic attraction yeah
yeah right but so then the question is
why
i mean
i see so if the thing has a great big
dipole moment
does that make it more likely to have
large van der waals forces
is that what determines it
and i mean that might not be if it has a
great big dipole moment maybe that the
vacuum fluctuations will do different
things to it as well
but then it would be very soluble in a
polar solvent yeah i was just saying
yeah yeah and as soon as you start using
nitrogen and oxygen in these molecules
uh
that that means you know you want to use
polar solvents and they tend to well
they could be more soluble with a
solvent but they would also have more
hooks to to use on each other to stick
i see but
polar means what that it's an um like
water or something where the thing is
yeah um that there's a dipole a local
dipole um
yeah where you've got more electrons in
one part than another basically okay now
you've chemistry question why does that
help with solubility
well with a polar solvent you you can
solvate the water you know or whatever
the polar solvent is has dipoles also
and you can get favorable dipole
interactions
with the solvent molecules which makes
that stable
and therefore they would be soluble um
[Music]
yeah
okay
yeah
right but they could also you know form
stable dipole interactions with other
molecules you know other solute
molecules and then you start getting
crystallization
and precipitation
right but but knowing how these things i
mean let's pick a random molecule like
this
how that thing makes a crystal is kind
of non-trivial isn't it
these guys yeah
yeah
i mean that's a separate question which
is also quite interesting and i mean i
don't know whether we've ever because
that relates to this other problem that
i've been looking at about these you
know random tilings and so on that is
when these form a crystal
okay next naive question when they form
a crystal what forces whole for
molecules like this
what makes them crystallize because
normally i mean like a sodium chloride
crystal it's all ionic stuff it's all
ionic stuff yeah charge attraction here
it would be the hydrophobic interactions
the the van der waals interactions
so there are crystals that that form
from vanderbilt's forces
yeah yeah i mean uh things like uh
benzene will crystallize
temperature
about it but so so is it the case
whenever organic in organic chemistry
when things
you know become solid
they
okay next now you question do they all
form crystals or do some of them just
make amorphous stuff
some like amorphous stuff you know
and you can't get them to crystallize or
they yeah
they're very some things can be very
difficult to crystallize yes
but if you have the right nucleation in
things and you have the right conditions
and you kind of let the thing go slowly
will it then crystallize or are the ones
that just never crystallize
it it's an art and you can get it to
happen um
we have a very big electrical storm here
so i might get cut off by losing my
internet so just to let you know okay
you're going crystal's an art form so i
mean
yeah
yes
right well okay this is all interesting
stuff do we need um we we should wrap up
here but but um uh anything we need to
say in terms of roadmap i mean we've got
yes yes i think so
a few additional steps in terms of
how we can direct this towards molecular
computing would be helpful so there's
this you know automated theorem proving
case i can discuss that with nick
but
but in general okay so we have these
tags
you know what what next how do we get
closer to molecular computing
yeah i i we need to think about this i
mean i think we need to think a bit more
um i i think it would be interesting to
look at the kind of qsar embeddings of
um
uh if that makes any sense so that you
know whatever the
embeddings of these graphs
for example if we just took this graph
and we know i don't know boiling points
of these things what would this you know
roughly i think that would be
interesting to see
what would the future space plot be
yes quite
right for a feature
like
um
you know
that would be a
i mean because when we get when we try
to reduce this to practice
yeah that will be important
um so i'm just getting some sense of
that because in the case of you know in
the case of
theorems in mathematics
the only way we lay theorems out in
theorem space
is
pretty much through their
entanglements aka common ancestry we
don't have a good way of saying this
formula
is this distance away from that formula
but in chemistry
there are some intrinsic properties of
these molecules like boiling points and
things
so we do have some other alternative
coordinate systems i guess that's the
question is what coordinate systems can
we use
um okay and
molecular fingerprints whatever those
might be
um represent some coordinatization of
the space of molecules and it'll be
interesting how do those work typically
those molecular fingerprint things
basically their
graph and variance uh
counts of graph substructures of various
sizes and shapes those kind of like
these weiner indices that are used for
boiling point estimates and things is
that right
yes yeah those are the simplest early
ones
okay okay fine so i mean that so that's
a way that we can coordinate eyes
molecular space
that'll be interesting to see yeah now
another question
uh
okay so you know our big hint is biology
and um
uh
i know we're we're running
low on time but let me just see whether
i have one thing here which i was hoping
does anybody happen to know where my
what was that name of that thing
what was the name of the um with the
game
the game what was that called was it
nanoscape
yes i think that's right let me see
whether this is installed on this
machine
yeah nanoscape
this could be very scary what's about to
happen
um
let's see
well you're looking for that the other
idea that you mentioned earlier stephen
that i liked was compile computation
into graph rewriting and then translate
that to chemical reactions
yes that's interesting
if we can find a nice bijection there
that sounds like something that's
feasible
right so the question is in graph
rewriting how do we do practical
computations with graph rewriting gosh i
tried to do that back in the mid-80s for
a way of doing uh parallel computing but
i didn't really understand it very well
i mean i i think i understand it better
now let me see can i start this game
hold on one second no no escape
god
oh for god's freaking sake
no
my password of my virtual machine is is
help
that's crazy
help is too simple stephen no no no no
no
yeah
that's crazy
oh don't say it out loud we're being
recorded i know i know i know
[Music]
if it's my ldap password it doesn't
appear to be an ldap password
i wonder whether it's in my password
manager
um
don't screen share that
i'm not screen showing that
i'm uh
nope not there
um
well uh okay i really wanted to by the
way can you see that that screen or can
you see whatever it is the lake or
whatever it
okay
is
um so if we can only uh log into this
thing
i have no idea where the lake is but if
we can only log into this thing we
should be able to see this nanoscape
game
um
somebody might have to text roger
yeah i'm reaching out i'll try to get as
soon as i can
okay
um
okay
so
uh
graph rewriting
right graph rewriting compiling things
into graph rewriting
i mean we've already done a little bit
of that in the physics project technical
introduction
i already looked at
some degree of you know turn combinators
into graph rewriting and so on
um
uh
but i consider that okay
the case that i really want to look at
is the analogy with molecular biology
and the question of whether i mean so in
this graph
okay in this graph normally in chemistry
we were just talking about what is the
concentration of each molecule but this
graph has a lot more information in it
about
you know so the question is
okay so for example here's an example of
a question
in chemistry the fact that there is this
event that leads to other molecules etc
the fact that there is um
a holonomy the fact that there is
non-trivial topology in this graph what
consequence does that have for chemistry
in other words the fact that there is a
that there are two different paths that
get to the same thing that's the
question that's what we found in the
case of games
things like you know towers of hanoi
there are multiple different
topologically distinct pathways that get
to the same result
we don't really know what the
significance of that is in mathematics
either
but that's a that's a feature of
chemistry that i don't know whether
anybody you know that's perhaps
something that is not
you know that's that's the question of
the dynamic structure
of the token event graph
that would be irrelevant to synthetic
chemistry i think
or would it no it would be very relevant
because that's your number of steps
involved in your you know in your your
synthesis plan no but what we're saying
bob is that there are two different
paths right they both lead to the same
both roads lead to the same result right
but one path is longer
it's likely to produce your result in
lower yield yeah i understand but what
you want then is the winning path that's
all you care about the fact that there
are multiple paths albeit of different
lengths that get there is not something
you care about
whereas i'm saying another feature of
this network
is that there are multiple parts
and the question is does that matter
in terms of relation to biology i mean
i do wonder if
either the molecules that organisms
commonly use or the ones that we find in
our biosphere if those are ones that
also enjoy some high density in
metachemical space you know like they
they arise
through many ways
um they have a high
not right either they have a high end
degree so i mean my utility as it
were well potentially utility or
synthesizability
yeah
right i mean that is a good question you
know i looked in the nks book for
example i looked at
okay so here's a good question actually
for a picture like this
which ones are in chemical abstracts
are all of these molecules and chemical
abstracts or only some of them
i would say some of them
okay are these are these tar like you
know precipitates at the periphery are
they really going to be in abstracts
i don't know it's a rhetorical question
well originally abstracts would only
give a a registry number to compounds
that were actually made but sometime in
the 80s or 90s they
started allowing uh
hypothetical structures as well really
into abstracts okay
well that's because the computational
chemistry community came about and we
were they wanted to index the things
that we were talking about
yeah
right but okay but so
so the thing we could potentially do
here is
annotate this picture with which ones
actually occur
in biology for example and that would be
kind of interesting to see because
that gives us i mean that is the analog
oh gosh you know that all these things
are so freaking connected yeah in
metamathematics
we can generate all the different
theorems but only some theorems have
names yeah i sent an email about that
last night yeah it's the same question
yes exactly right the i mean in other
words we can generate all these
molecules but only some of the molecules
and molecules that we care about
that's right all the biology cares about
that's right and biology has had
you know doesn't
its preferencing mechanisms are a little
different
um
let me just uh
um
one second here
um
the i'm i'm sorry i'm reminded of by the
way
in terms of observatory did i i don't
know if i told you this but but um i
took that uh particle detector
on a plane
last
weekend fireworks right it's just a
spectacular number of particle events
yeah which
um
it's just 35 000 feet yeah yeah yeah and
including ones and michael may be able
to recognize this i don't know i haven't
really looked at this yet but but um
uh
where the heck did i put this this is
not one of those things that one
immediately knows where to put it oh
here we go
um
let me just see here
uh
oh no i thought this was um i thought
roger had sent me
the thing oh well i maybe can't can't
show this here um
but uh
uh there are a bunch of v's which i
think
maybe other people i think those are
strange particle production i think
those are the so-called v particles
those are associated production events
but i know i've never seen a strange
particle in the flesh so to speak or you
know
if there were strange particles in this
little particle detector sitting on my
computer then i'm sure they were once
being produced in me by cosmic rays um
while that was going on so to speak but
anyway it's it's kind of kind of
interesting you can really see
actual you know lots of actual particle
events okay that was irrelevant um but
uh
anyway so annotating this
yeah sure right
um
okay but then
you know continuing the discussion of
biology and the reason i wanted to show
this nanoscape thing is because it is
trying to show a version of what's
happening in the cytoskeleton and other
kinds of
you know in a sense what we might call
solid directed
reactions
and i'm trying to get some sense of you
know in biochemistry
molecular biology how many interactions
really happen in this kind of liquid
phase chemistry type mode and how many
of them are organized by membranes and
other sort of solid
structures
maybe um
i think the vast majority
that sustain life are organized
do you know i think this thing had no
password
that's embarrassing
all right
okay let's see what happens here
oh my gosh
that's making weird noises but other
than the weird noises it's a black
screen
come on
skip the weird noises i just want to see
the insider
okay
oh no
what's happening here
is that
help where's my mouse
oh here we go
okay
okay we got weird eerie sounds but i
just want to see where
help how do i get anywhere what do i do
here
okay how do i switch off the stupid erie
sounds i guess i just say
mute
it's a good way to do it
okay
so what are we seeing here so we're
seeing a um a cell membrane
with a bunch of
oops did i
you know what can anybody
hello talk to me anybody there yeah okay
i don't think i can
i think if i mute it i can't hear us
yeah i can't hear you either
let's just see do we have any options
here
for i wonder if the virtual machine can
have it some oh wait a minute i see a
microphone thing up there where's my
mouse
where the heck is my mouse
i'm really confused here
uh
but so
some somebody give me a guided tour of
what i'm seeing here is this
anybody know what i mean so this is a
cell membrane
and these are molecules on the cell
surface right
proteins that are sticking out of it
probably yeah
okay yes and that and that great big
hole
that we need to
see now i i can really use twitch
properly because now i'm i'm streaming
some video game
um
okay what what are those holes oh god
look i'll take one
canals
probably pores yeah
but i would expect a lot of protein
around them as well
and what are those stringy things those
are pieces of the cytoskeleton those are
like
well if we're in the cytosol probably
but maybe it it's more like collagen
fibers on the outside between cells
okay so how do we think we get into the
cytosol do you think we can just die
down that hole drive it behind no i know
how do i get in the hole i don't know
you get your putter on your keyboard it
says
right like wsad maybe try to press w
and somebody on the on the chat probably
knows
oh it says in the beginning it's short
how to
navigate right yes i know but i wasn't
paying attention to that but can you
actually can you go in to the interior
well i don't know we don't know whether
they've got the immaturity i don't yeah
i don't know
okay so this is not as as exciting as
jesse could probably help
i right to fly an arduino down the hole
the
okay this isn't very exciting so this is
just the surface of the cell i want to
see inside the cell
now what's happening where are we here
can you can you look up you're kind of
staring at the well how do i look up i'm
pressing the yes
what does your mouse do does it control
well my mouse is lost
my mouse is just
somehow i can't i think my mouse has
been captured by the virtual machine
control
control alt to free cursor
control what's an alt
oh wow there we go i i got it okay fine
okay so then
oh no what's it doing
okay so maybe i'm
oh i see i have to press ctrl alt every
time i want to free the mouse
okay well this is clearly not some
uh
not
what is happening help
well okay we clearly need to have a
little bit more what's that that's
does that bring up the keyboard no
there's got to be some controls here
that let us do something why do they
make the lighting so wild
well i mean i don't know what this
project
help
okay well this has not been as
successful as i'd hoped i think it's
time to close this
window
no no no it did it won't go away
help
uh
what the heck it refuses to make
metastasis
i won't die
unable to suspend windows 10 because
there isn't enough
what the heck is this it says unable to
suspend windows 10 because there isn't
enough free disk space
okay i think it's time for us to wrap
our meeting yeah this is this is
horrifying
um okay see you all soon thanks to folks
on the live stream to be continued